mmm this pie is good
oh it really does feel the same
American Reunion now this is kind of a
nostalgic 90s trip when you watch the
trailer for this movie which I actually
avoided doing before seeing it I went
back and I rewatched with after seeing
the film it has got 90s power blast
nostalgia to the face all over it which
is very appealing to me the 90s was like
my time it's when everything just kind
of culminated into awesomeness loving
movies and just discovering all kinds of
things I love the 90s was my time and
prior to seeing American Reunion I had
only seen the first film which I enjoy
about it was a fun silly movie I loved
that kind of 90s high school comedies it
just has a fun vibe to it reminds me of
my childhood so going to this movie I
was optimistic so I was thinking why
would they make a sequel so late in the
game they must have something they want
to tell you know they want to bring back
those old feelings a nostalgia get you
back in that vibe of yes I remember you
know back in the 90s and early 2000s
when high school was cool and when
everything was happening and it was just
you know you did feeling you know what I
mean so basically what's happening is
you got the whole original crew back
from the first three films and they are
not having a big high school reunion yet
Stifler goes honestly my favorite
character of all of those films he is
just the scene-stealing douche of all
douches he is just a jock idiot but he
is hilarious and Sean William Scott is
just perfect for that role and I'm so
surprised to me to tell you that I
actually loved this movie this movie
just hit all the right notes for me yes
it was a huge gross out comedy but it
just had the right amount of heart to it
that really had me latched on to these
characters and reminded me of my youth
in the 90s there were so many songs that
came on throughout this movie I was like
oh my god they're playing the freshmen I
mean the freshmen buy the Verve pipe
they used to be like my favorite song in
like the late 90s I adored that song
they played poison I mean that song is
one of my favorite lines of all time
never trust a big butt in a smile and
that is a model that I live by this
movie just had everything I wanted it to
have all the characters are back in
their original glory
there was good heartfelt moments in this
movie too it wasn't just mindless
sophomoric comedy there was a lot of
that trust me and my audience was
roaring the preview audience I saw this
with they flat-out loved this movie they
were clapping and just just cheering and
it was a great audience to see this film
with and he
one of the reasons why I thought this
movie works so well it really explored
what happens to a person when they leave
high school and they start experiencing
life they're looking back and they want
to relive those days they want their
childhood back they want all those fun
times but they're getting jobs their
friends are getting married people are
having children a lot of people didn't
want to grow up they wanted to stay a
kid forever they wanted to you know keep
those same vibes that you had when you
were in high school or college and this
movie really explores how that changes
it did kind of a similar thing to 21
Jump Street did when they went back to
high school and the whole idea of cool
was different now Stifler is still
trying to go to some of these high
school parties with people and all the
things that he thought were cool aren't
cool anymore and he's kind of looked at
is a little creepy and and it's it's so
funny how it's such a short time period
the things that we're cool or popular
have changed so much and the film really
does a good job of exploring that it's
pretty obvious to say this film made me
laugh quite a bit I was really
entertained by this movie if you go into
this movie knowing that it is a very
sophomoric film but has a good sense of
heart I think you'll enjoy it if you
enjoyed the previous American Pie films
I'm sure you'll be satisfied I like this
one much more than the first one I have
yet to watch 2 & 3 but I think it's a
great film I really enjoyed American
Reunion good characters great nostalgic
feeling I really thought the script was
well written it had a lot of moments
where you're so tense because lots of
embarrassing humor moments where
characters are trying to get out of
situations they're somehow in and stuff
keeps piling on you're like oh my word
this is terrible but it's so
entertaining I really enjoyed American
Reunion I'm going to give American
Reunion and a - I thought it was a lot
of fun if you're a fan of the original
films we grew up in the 90s
I'm sure this movie will be a lot of fun
for you - do you have a favorite 90s
movie or a movie that just means a lot
to you that makes you feel nostalgic
when you watch it you're like yeah that
man that reminds me of when I was a kid
or something along those lines just a
movie that makes you feel really good
and remember the glory days as always if
you like this review you can subscribe
to my channel and get steppen eyes